there are things that charlotte
worthington does on her bmx
that just look impossible a few years
back she was working as a chef in a
mexican restaurant in manchester
dreaming of a day like this and she
dared to try new moves it was a 360
backflip
that landed a gold we've been searching
for like this
this gold medal trick essentially that
that was going to get us there and there
was a couple of things we thought it
might have been and then
once i started trying this trick and it
just kind of came
and we were like that's it that's the
one
max whitlock was already team gb's
greatest ever gymnast but he
too found another level retaining his
olympic title on the pommel horse
with an incredibly hard routine that he
made look easy
through lockdowns he's used his garden
as his gym
but nothing could knock him off course
in defending his title from rio
he's 28 but determined to go to paris
for the next olympics i can't believe
that's just happened
um thank you everybody it's been an
incredible journey team gb
everybody so grateful to have that
moment with scot on the floor of me
cannot believe i'm coming home with gold
medal thank you so much for everybody's
support it means the world
but the biggest british success has been
in the pool where the four by 100 men's
team landed silva
a spectacular week that all started with
adam peaty's breaststroke victory for us
it's kind of the ball started rolling
and i think you know what i'm latched on
to that and duncan did and tom dean did
once that momentum was carrying forward
you know he started off and i think
that's where it came from that's where
it's been coming from since rio we're
not just going to sit back and go oh
that's that's amazing of course we are
for
a brief moment but we're always looking
okay how can we peak again how can we
get better from this and then and that's
the shift that we've made
and that's the shift that every team
should make we shouldn't have to sit on
the fruits of our labour and just be
happy
duncan scott has four of those precious
medals
the most of any team gb athlete in one
olympics
the thing that is really positive that
was 22 of the team
it's their first ever olympics and so
there is a lot of young faces on the
team and
and ready to for the next three years to
to move things on which
which i think is great it is now the
point at which olympic games
start to be judged and that comes down
to moments
and medals in rio five years ago they
took home
an incredible 67 medals we are now over
halfway through these tokyo games
and that record is in their sights while
british rowing has slipped back and
athletics is still waiting for a big
moment
the pendulum has swung towards new
sports that are vying for attention
and the ones that are really delivering
the goods
tom parmenter sky news tokyo